der mutmaßliche serienkiller timo aus
regensburg soll zwei prostituierte
umgebracht haben
eine der frauen soll er mit einer
plastiktüte erstickt haben die andere
auf seinem dachboden in plastikfolie
versteckt seit letzter woche sitzt der
möbel fahrer in u-haft heute sucht die
mordkommission nach weiteren möglichen
opfern und gräbt seinen kompletten
schrebergarten um
ich möchte jetzt sprechen mit meinem
kollegen jan hendrik dowe jan warum wird
jetzt in den kleingärten gewühlt was
versucht man zu finden
ja guten morgen aus rendsburg ohne
liegend ist eben der tod einer
prostituierten aus rendsburg im laufe
der ermittlungen haben dann die
ermittler auf einem dachboden in dem
wohnhaus in denen timo erlebte eine
weitere frauenleiche die noch
unidentifizierte gefunden
und weil eben die ermittler davon
ausgehen dass wenn es mittlerweile schon
zwei tote frauen gibt die mutmaßlich
diesen tatverdächtigen zu gerechnet
werden kann es eben auch sein dass in
diesem kleinen garten den der harz
verdächtige lebte und zudem der zugang
hatte nun auch ja ein weiterer
schrecklicher fund entdeckt werden
könnte und wie sieht die suche aktuell
genau aus nun heute morgen um 9 uhr 45
sind hier ermittler mit schwerem gerät
erfordern leichenspürhunden angerückt
hinter mir das ist jetzt in ungefähr 25
meter entfernung sind sie nun dabei das
erdreich bohrern zu öffnen um eventuelle
leichen gerüche reize setzen damit im
nachgang hier die leichenspürhunde event
oder nachschärfen überresten suchen
können alles ist natürlich nie sicher
dass hier überhaupt etwas gefunden
werden könnte
doch die möglichkeit besteht weil es ein
sehr junger uneinsehbare gelände ist
dort ist auch noch mal eine hecke hinter
dem gewächshaus und dort kann man
natürlich
gerade zu zeiten im moment hält sich
hier auch kaum einer auf in der
kleingartenanlage in denen hier kaum
einer ist kann man hier werkeln ohne
dass man groß beobachtet wird und jan
was erhofft man sich von der suche noch
die ermittler sind natürlich ganz am
anfang ihrer arbeit und bei diesen
ermittlungen gibt es noch ganz viele
unbekannte zum beispiel wer war die
zweite leiche gefunden wurde und wer war
diese frau da gibt ganz viele ansätze
denen die ermittler noch nachgehen
müssen
und sie haben eben die hoffnung dass das
auch noch spuren gibt es einen möglichen
orten an denen neben timo emsig aufhielt
und dieses areal dass sie hier
durchsuchen und vorgaben wird ist sehr
groß und es gibt viele erdlöcher in
denen eventuell noch was schlummert was
wissen wir noch über timo m über den
täter hatte timo ist sozusagen der 40
jährige lebte bis zu seiner festnahme
ende oktober mit seiner freundin in dem
haus wo auch die zweite leiche gefunden
wurde
er ist als möbel auslieferer angestellt
gewesen hatte zuvor auch eine partnerin
in einer anderen norddeutschen stadt
gehabt wenn wir der zusammenlebte und er
war jemand der ja ich würde sagen ein
sehr ruhiger mensch gewesen ist aber
jemand der sich an vielen orten in
schleswig-holstein aufgehalten hat und
es gab auch in der vergangenheit
ermittlungsverfahren gegen und die waren
immer im zusammenhang mit sexualdelikten
tatsache ist aber dass bis zum mord an
der prostituierten um den safina geht
und den weiteren leichenfund es kein
ermittlungsverfahren gab das irgendwie
zu einer und verurteilung geführt hatte
somit gibt es da auch für die
ermittlungsbehörden noch aufzuklären
und trotzdem meine frage jetzt nochmal
wie geht die polizei in diesem
besonderen fall um auch mit diesen
besonderen milieus ja das milieu in dem
die recherchen oder bzw
die ermittlungen sich bewegen ist
natürlich ja die szene der freiherr ist
in dem fall so gewesen dass timo m über
einen eigenen portal kontakt mit der
prostituierten die er dann ermordete
aufgenommen hatte mutmaßlich ist was
auch mit der zweiten frau so gewesen
das wissen wir journalisten noch nicht
die ermittlungsbehörden wissen das ist
wahrscheinlich und er hat dich ja man
kann sagen er hat so eine art sein leben
auch geführt er hat er auf der einen
seite sei niederes partnerschaft leben
davor auch das partnerschafts leben mit
der ex freunde aber er hat nachweislich
in den letzten zwei jahren auch immer
wieder mit prostituierten verkehrt und
diese kontakte muss die polizei
natürlich jetzt auch aufklären
nachverfolgen und kann somit vielleicht
auch die letzten zwei jahre dieses
tatverdächtigen besser nachvollziehen
wir sind bild und wie ihr liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier und vergiss bitte
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren